JJ, how you doing? Peace to you. I
didn't think you'd get to me. How are
you? I'm I'm good. Welcome. Welcome to
the pan. May I ask you a question? Sure.
Why do you think the Quran was given or
created?
Um, it could be because
uh of influence, a desire to have
influence, a desire to have power, and a
desire to have authority, women, stuff
like that. I I I've been following you
for a while, so I know you're versed in
the Quran also. So, where in it are
these indications of what you speak of
as far as control? Sure. You got um
chapter 33 kind of lays it out about
like showing kind of special treatment
for Muhammad that he gets to kind of get
whatever woman throws themsel at him
without a real limit while um the
Muslims are like the regular men.
They're not allowed to have multiple
wives outside of the number of four. All
right. So if you go to chapter 33 you
see that Muhammad gets special
privileges with that. And then there's a
hadith in regards to this where Aisha
herself says, "It seems like your Lord
hastens to fulfill your desires, you
know, and that was pretty telling to
me." So if we go to chapter 33. Oh,
there you go. You're cutting out, JJ. I
just want to make it clear to you. Yeah.
I don't know why. Can you hear me or No,
it's better now. Yeah. No, it's better
now. Okay. I just I just wanted to make
it clear to you. I'm Quran only. So I
don't I don't engage with hadiths at
all. So Okay. Just to be clear. Okay,
fair enough. So I won't I won't bring
hadith to you since you don't hold that
as authoritative. That wouldn't be fair
in this conversation. So So what what
are your thoughts then on on 3350 to 52
that talks about like uh the women
giving themselves to Muhammad and he's
able to accept any of them. He can deny
them if he wants. Um and he can accept
them back after he denied them. What
what do you what are your thoughts on
that? Well, as I read through the Quran,
I see that certain things in the Quran
were specific for a certain time, and
this is seems to be one of them, a
certain time and place. And I can't
answer what Allah's thinking was to
allow this. So, but I don't see how this
is applicable to today or how this
warrants it being written to somehow
undermine the scriptures previous to it.
So, yeah. So, I I don't I don't think
that I don't think that the Quran has a
purpose to override the scriptures
previous to it. Like we see throughout
the Quran that it it gives this picture
that it's in line with what came before
it. Not not that it overrides it or is
against it in any way, but correcting
the people who deviate from their
scriptures and who are lying or trying
to conceal it and distort with their
tongues, misinterpret, it condemns them.
But you know, it gives it's it's always
for the previous books. My thing is is
that we see you know situations within
the Quran that's tend to personally
benefit Muhammad like and this would be
one of them like he's personally getting
this benefit of having whatever woman he
wants. What what does this have to do
with the revelation of God and his
guidance and like this has nothing to do
like it does nothing like you said it
does nothing for you today. It doesn't
doesn't do anything for you. It doesn't
even do anything for them the believers
at that time like well how does that
help them? doesn't this this is just
showing up like Muhammad's proclivities
are being you know being indulged in.
Yeah. Um I I cannot and I cannot
honestly respond to that because I I
don't know I don't know what the thought
process is. However, what following
Jesus for 40 years and being led to the
Quran, what I get from the Quran is the
message of all the prophets that there
is only one God, that there will be a
judgment day and to do good. So that
consistency doesn't seem to be in
contradiction to the previous
scriptures, especially Jesus's
teachings. Okay. Well, so I would say
believing in one God, that's pretty
good. That's pretty solid. There is a
judgment day. That's pretty solid as
well. But how you receive salvation is
completely different from what the Quran
teaches in what the previous pro matter
of fact, here's something actually that
interesting that I've learned. The word
salvation doesn't even appear in the
Quran. Did you know that? Like the word
salvation, being saved, it does not it
does not appear in the Quran. And this
was a heavy theme for Jesus for example
and the previous prophets, they always
pointed to the salvation of the Lord
coming. The salvation of the Lord, it's
on its way. And Jesus said, "The
salvation of the Lord is here. It's in
me." Right? Whoever believes in me shall
be saved. Right? And I will raise him up
on the last day. What you what do you
have uh your thoughts on that? I I I I
I'm sorry. I don't I I really don't see
it as as a contradiction. I w I was
genuine when I when I came up. I really
wanted to see I understand that you're
against the Quran, but I don't
understand why. And what you've what
you've offered to me is the special
treatment of the prophet. Well, you
know, it's it's written in there about
if you go by his house, do not stay too
long after you eat and do not yell to
him from outside. Why that's in the
Quran? I have no idea. But it doesn't
make it any any less credible the
message that it carries. You know what I
mean? Yeah. Let me let me tell you
exactly why. Okay. The the reason my
main reason why I reject the Quran is
because it goes against the teachings of
the prophets. When I when I read what
Moses taught, what Jesus taught, you
know, what the prophets taught, when I
see their consistent message, I do see
that the Quran explicitly contradicts
what they what they teach. One of the
things is this. Yes. I'm sorry. Go
ahead. No. So, yeah, one So, one of the
things is that we Jesus teaches and this
is one of the most famous verses in the
gospel. For God so loved the world that
he gave his only begotten son, right?
That whoever believes in him will not
perish but have everlasting life. Right?
And he says that that whoever believes
in the name of the son of God is going
to be saved. Whoever doesn't, they're
condemned already. That's John 3:16 to
18. Now, if that's Jesus's message of
salvation, the Quran comes and says to
to say that Allah has a son, you have
uttered an atrocious thing. In chapter
9:30, it says the Christians say that
Jesus is the son of Allah. That is their
own saying. They are imitating the
disbelievers from before. How diluted
they are from the truth. May Allah's
curse be upon them for saying Jesus is
the son of Allah. So this is a direct
contradiction in a core doctrine of the
teaching of Jesus. But but but what you
quoted out of John, my Bible's up on the
shelf there. What you quoted out of
John, you're saying that Jesus said
those words? Yes. Saying that John says
says this of of Jesus. Well, G Jesus
John is recording what Jesus was saying.
So So Jesus is speaking and John is
recording it. Okay. I' I've never read
it that way. Quite honestly, and I I
think you might agree with me within the
Gospels. You have the three gospels.
They seem to be Matthew, Mark, and Luke
seem to be pretty consistent. John is
the one that takes us out there into the
world of divinity. Wouldn't you agree?
No, sir. when I like Mark Mark's gospel
literally starts off like this JJ Mark's
Markap 1 verse one it says this is the
gospel of Jesus Christ the son of God
that's how Mark starts off you know and
they you know if you talk about liberal
scholars they say that Mark was the
earliest gospel and then they'll try to
argue like this there's this development
of high christologology this de deifying
Christ comes like through the later the
the further you go up till John, but I
we we're like, "What the heck?" Those
who of us who read the Bible, we're
like, "Where are you getting this from?"
Mark literally starts off with the deity
of Christ in it. Yeah. You see, well,
that's sort of um consistent with, you
know, when Jesus Jesus is I I forget
which gospel it is, but Jesus is walking
along and he says, "Who who do they say
that I am?" And that's when when Peter
says, "Thou art the Christ, the son of
the living God." Right?
And Jesus says, "Upon this rock I'll
build my church." The my understanding
of that was I I can't imagine a person
like Peter or anybody else in that time
of Jewish belief, Israeli Jewish I guess
belief, Hebrew belief to think that
there would be a physical manifestation
of God on earth. I I and as I said, I
followed Jesus's teachings for years. I
I never got from him that he was telling
me he was God, but I always got from him
that he was he when when he says him he
he typically refer himself as the son of
man, you know, not the son of God. Do
you know why that's significant, JJ? The
the son of man. Well, because it's
consistent it's consistent with Old
Testament writings. Yeah. Specifically,
Daniel 7. Listen, look. Daniel 7. That's
where we see this appearance of the one
like a son of man. That's where we get
this title from. It originates from
Daniel 7. Okay. And in the f is it the
furnace? No, not not not the furnace.
Not the furnace, but this is a vision
that Daniel's having. But I know I know
what you're talking about where where
the king
Nebuchadnezz that pops up in the
furnace, right? Yeah. Yeah. But yeah,
you you see him there, too. But um so so
watch this. So we see uh this is who the
son of man is. Uh this is Daniel 7
starting at verse 13 and 14. He says, "I
saw in the night visions. And behold,
with the clouds of heaven there came one
like a son of man. And he came to the
ancient of days and was presented before
him. And to him was given dominion and
glory and a kingdom that all peoples,
nations, and languages should serve
him." His dominion is an everlasting
dominion which shall not pass away and
his kingdom one that shall not be
destroyed. So we see here that the son
of man is this divine figure who's
presented before the ancient of days who
rules with him rules alongside him
forever and how all creatures of the
world will will serve him. Yeah. You see
I I I I'm familiar with that and you and
you did a good job uh reading it. the
the one who appears as the son of man
before the ancient of days. See there I
see as two individual things God
almighty and Jesus going with what
you're suggesting. So from that point,
look, I don't know how it's all going to
turn out. And Daniel Daniel is saying
that this is a vision in the future
after judgment day because according to
the Quran, Jesus is going to stand as a
witness for the people of the book. So
after judgment day, I don't know what's
going to happen. Yeah. You know, but but
see, okay, so if I may, the son of man
thing, if I say anything against Jesus,
who calls himself the son of man, I am
forgiven for that. Because Jesus says,
"Behold, if you say anything against the
son of man, it shall be forgiven. But to
say anything against the spirit of God,
that shall never be forgiven." Yes.
Yeah. If you if you blasphe the son of
man, if you blaspheme Jesus, then you
know you can be forgiven for that. If
you blasphem the holy spirit, then that
is that's different. And really the
interpretation of that is that the Holy
Spirit is is consistently pulling on
people and trying and drawing us to
Christ. It's by him that we're able to
say that Christ is Lord. And so
blaspheming the Holy Spirit is an is an
ultimate rejection of him. And without
the Holy Spirit, we do not have a
regeneration of our heart and we're not
born again. And that's why we won't be
forgiven for blaspheming the Holy Spirit
because we're rejecting that
regeneration that is necessary for
salvation. Right? So even the whole time
that I'm walking with Jesus in 40 years,
holding on to his teachings, but not
being part of the I the idea of Trinity
or anything like that, but holding on to
Jesus's teachings for all of that time.
I I understood him to be a man. I
understood him to be a prophet. Okay.
And I I never called him I I I didn't
call him God. I don't think of him as
God. So, and when I I'm sorry. Go ahead.
No. So, let me let me ask you this just
with the son of man thing, right? So,
this is what when Jesus is at his trial
and and this is what the high priest
asked him this and his response. Watch.
He says, "Are you the Christ?" Again,
the high priest asked him. This is Mark.
This is Mark, by the way. Mark chapter
14. So we're not in John or anything
like that. So he says again the high
priest asked him, "Are you the Christ,
the son of the blessed?" Right? And
Jesus said, "I am." Right? So being the
Messiah, being the Christ is being the
son of God. He says, "I am." Right? And
then he says, right? And you will see
the son of man seated at the right hand
of the power and coming with the clouds
of heaven. And at the response of this,
go ahead. No, and to your very good
because that's consistent with Daniel's
vision, but I'm sorry I interrupted. Go
ahead. So when Jesus utters this JJ, the
high priest tore his garment and said,
"What further witnesses do you need? You
heard his blasphemy." Now Jesus is
claiming to be the son of man who is the
son of God who sits at the right hand of
the father on high and rides the clouds
of heaven. How do you not see that he's
claiming to be more than just a mere
man? Oh no. I believe me I I haven't
made complete sense of it but it my the
Quran has told me that the the
relationship between the Almighty and
Jesus was that of Adam and and the
Almighty. Uh the Almighty said be and he
was no Jesus is on a whole different
level. A whole different level. Yeah.
And but to your point it see I've always
if he's at the right hand of the father
like Jesus says behold I am the way.
Well you've most Christians have taken
the way and made it also the
destination. It can't be both. If if
he's sitting at the right hand of the
father he's not the father. But I have
to admit to you and I have to be honest.
Since coming to Islam, this whole idea
of father and son has got me old. I
really I'm telling you I can't make 40
years I prayed to God as father. Yeah.
Because that's what Jesus taught me to
do. So exactly I don't know any answers
to that. So this so this is uh just just
to touch on the the way point and I
think that you made a good one. It's
actually an interesting one. It's not
mutually exclusive where he's either the
way or the destination because all
right, let me just actually be clear.
You're right. There is a distinction
between Jesus and the father. He's the
son and our heavenly father is the
father. They're not the same person.
Okay? So, Christians do not affirm that
Jesus is the father. We would never say
that. Whoever is saying that is in
error. Okay? The Bible is pretty clear.
There's a distinction between those
persons. However, they're perfectly
united in their essence and in their
purpose and their will. when it comes to
Jesus saying that he's the way right he
says no one can come to the father
except through me right no one can come
to the father except through me so he's
showing that he's the way to the father
but not just that he also claims to be
the destination as well he says in
Matthew 11 this is what he says brother
in Matthew 11 he says this he says let
me pull it up Matthew 11 we're going to
do 27 to 30 I think it is okay so
Matthew Matthew
11:27 to 30. Yeah. Now Jesus says, are
you going to read? Yeah. Yeah, I'll read
it. Okay. Now he says this. Now this is
special. He says, "All
things have been handed over to me by my
father. And no one knows the son except
the father. And no one knows the father
except the son and whoever the son
chooses to reveal him." All right.
Right? So Jesus claims to have all
things that the father has. He claims to
be unknowable that only the father can
truly know him and only he knows truly
the father and he's the one who reveals
the father. Right? And then he goes and
says this, watch verse 28. This is the
part where he's the destination. He says
in verse 28, "Come to me all who labor
and are heavy laden and I will give you
rest. Take my yoke upon you and learn
from me for I am gentle and lowly in
heart and you will find rest for your
souls for my yoke is easy and my burden
is light. So yes, Jesus is the way to
the father and his revelation to the
father but our rest is in Jesus himself.
Our rest is in Jesus. Where our burden
is let go it's in him. So he's both the
destination and the way. What are your
your thoughts so far? Well, you see the
the issue um quite often that I have
with Jes See, I consider Jesus when when
I read his, you know, if I take a a red
letter edition of the Bible, let's say,
and I'm reading that, I in my mind,
Jesus was a walking, talking, living
Quran. He was the message from God.
That's really how I understood it. And
so a lot of times when he speaks you
know he like Jesus will say quite often
I what I do is not of me it's the father
that does the work what I say is me it's
the father you know so a lot of times
when he like to answer your question is
roundabout way but come unto me yes I I
can see it easily being interpreted and
understood as coming to Jesus for for
the the peace
But I always took Jesus as one who was
leading me to God, to the God of God of
everything, God of all the worlds. But
so do do you see how it's not either or?
He's both leading you to the father and
bringing you to himself. It's both.
Yeah. Well, I I I understand what you're
saying. I do I do understand what you're
saying. But as you were leading up to
that, you you mentioned a couple of
things. You mentioned essence and will.
Yeah. And in the garden of Gethsemane,
there seems to be a a
differentiation between will. Yeah.
Nevertheless, I will be done. Yeah.
Yeah. And and that is because will is a
property of your of your nature of your
essence. Right. And so uh because Jesus
has a human a human nature. He has a
human will that you know can waver that
can you know in the moment be be weak
and need to be brought into submission
and but he also has the divine nature
that he shares with the father and he
has that divine will with the father and
so when he says not let not my will be
done but your will be done this is where
he is bringing that human will under the
submission of the divine will that
divine will that he shares with the
father so yeah yes I I I've heard that
response and and it does it does hold
water. I understand it holds water in in
the the
the defending of Jesus's divinity. But
for me, I always found the leadup to
that line most curious because I never
really understood why it was mentioned
three times. Three separate Jesus goes
to the father three times in Gethsemane,
but it's mentioned three of the gospels,
which I always found interesting. Yeah.
And so, so here's the question. Jesus
says, "Nevertheless, thy will be done."
Mhm. Which is greater, love or
sacrifice? Love. Love is greater. And
that's what I discovered going to the
Quran because the Lord God Almighty
answered Jesus and spared him from the
crucifixion. So yes, I agree with you.
Love is greater. And that's the message
that's supposed to unite all of these
religions. And that's that's that's the
part that we we would disconnect because
the love is that Jesus willingly goes
because he loves us. He willingly goes
and gives himself as a ransom for
mankind demonstrating his love. I mean
literally Jesus says this. There's no
greater love than this that a man lay
that one lays down his life for his
friends. And so that is a sacrificial
love, but it's the substance of that is
love nonetheless. And so you have Jesus
with his love demonstrating his love,
the greatest form of love in giving his
life despite the despair and the grief
that he's feeling. And yes, the father
even loves the son where he doesn't
abandon him but raises him up from the
dead. He doesn't stay there. Death
doesn't hold him. He raises him up and
vindicates him. Yeah. No, I understand.
And from a my Christian uh background, I
I I'm familiar with that train of
thought. See, our religions, Jewish,
Christian, and Islam, Jewish, Christian,
Muslim, they're all based on Abraham. So
when I go to the Quran and I see that
the Lord God Almighty spared Jesus, I go
back to Abraham when Abraham was asked
to sacrifice his son and his willingness
was all God was looking for. So in
Gethsemane I think it's written three
times for us to ponder on why is this
why is this and for me to respect the
Quran came down to make clear all of
this but it didn't I do well it did for
me but okay so so JJ this is what you
this is the conundrum that you would be
in with the Quran you would have to
you're going to have to deal with the
ambiguity of the situation what's going
on. Why Jesus is even being put on a
cross? What is the purpose of this? Him
actually going to like when we see when
we keep reading the story, he willingly
goes and gets crucified. And not only
that, he points to a passages that
foretell what's happening to him
beforehand, right? He he he quotes Psalm
22. My God, my God, why have you
forsaken me? Why are you so far from my
groaning? And it talks about how he's
being mocked. He's surrounded by his
enemies and they have pierced my hands
and my feet. You lay me in the dust of
death yet you are my vindicator, right?
You are my redeemer and in you your, you
know, righteousness is shown or
whatever. Or Isaiah 53. Isaiah 53 tells
us that he's acquainted with griefs and
carrying our sorrows. So in the garden
of Gethsemane, when we're seeing Jesus
grieved and sorrowful, the prophets
already told us that he's going to be
feeling this, that he's going to be
familiar with this. So, it shouldn't
surprise us when Jesus is in the garden
of Gethsemane and he's crying out to the
father and having the most intense
prayers of all time because it's it's
not on the cross that Jesus first starts
to, you know, feel the weight of the sin
of the world. It's at the garden of
Gethsemane. That's where it begins.
That's where he enters that, you know,
and the prophets already foretold us.
So, now if that didn't happen or if
let's say God rescued him from the
crucifixion, he never died. he was
actually saved. Um, he did not give his
life. That would make the prophets
before Jesus liars who said that the
Messiah would give his life and would
bear the sin of many and would have his
hands and feet pierced. Yeah.
Absolutely. And the whole time that I'm
following Jesus, the whole time that I'm
I'm in those gospels and I'm reading it
and I'm trying to understand it still
when I get to Gethsemane, it causes me
to have there's a stumbling block there
because Jesus had told us as we're
going, he says, "We're going to
Jerusalem. Behold, I'm going to be
offered up by, you know, and and he and
I'll be raised on the third day." So, he
has prepared us, but yet when we get to
Gethsemane, he he seems to falter. And I
don't know if you've and I won't take up
a lot more of your time. I'm sure you
have a lot of guests that want to come
up, but I don't know if you've ever
considered the chapter in the Quran, the
spread table, where Jesus's disciples
say, "Can you bring us down uh food from
heaven so that we may so that we may be
reassured of your teachings of who you
are?" And and the Lord God Almighty
says, "Behold, I will send it down, but
whoever deviates afterwards, there will
be a punishment upon them greater than
any that I've ever put on any of my
creatures, any of creation." And for me,
that's for me that hints at the
situation. I think Jesus was supposed to
be crucified. And I think that the Lord
God Almighty decided on a better plan.
And I just and I but I have but I have
to say to you sir I I was I'm very
grateful that you you allowed me up and
you've answered my question questions
and I we're not in agreement but I think
we're in like spirit because I sense
that a genuiness from you and a caring
from you. And what I've learned from
Jesus and from the Quran is what I've
said earlier. There is only one God.
There will be a judgment day. And until
that judgment day, do good. And I
believe that you and I, brother, will
see each other after judgment day. I
wish you peace. Thank you for having me
out. Thank thanks. Thanks for coming,
JJ. Yeah, guys. This is uh this is the
unfortunate truth to be to be led to
Islam. You know, you you have to ignore
and uh the lot of the prophets and you
make God out to be a liar.
Unfortunately, uh you make Jesus out to
be a liar. You know, you you there's no
way that you can affirm both. You cannot
you cannot affirm the teachings of Jesus
and the prophets and the teaching of
Muhammad at the same time because
Muhammad directly goes against
everything in substance of what the
prophets taught and what Jesus taught,
you know. So, it's really it's really
tough to because he was a gentle a
gentle gentleman, man. He was a he was a
gentleman. And so, yeah, we do disagree.
And it's it's it kind of it sucks to see
that. It sucks to see someone really
just miss miss the mark like that. Uh
who has a gentle spirit like he does.
It's tough to see that.